Minchia signora ma tutti sti panettoni
famiglia numerosa sono tutti per lei ma
tutte come metabolismo veloce siete io
ingrasso solo se lo guardo il panettone
vai in pausa me Beata te l'hanno già
fatta a fette stamattina signore bollini
li vuole
si può vincere un'agenda 2021 2022 non
li vuole non ho capito perché nessuno
volesse i Pollini No cosa si è
dimenticato il latte Sì però si muova se
no si crea la coda Oh è tornato Marcel
džekovs in tutto questo tempo gli andavo
a mungere direttamente io al latte
bancomat lo appoggi
Eh ma così si appoggia Cioè lo so
appoggiare meglio di lei che sono una
donna ti sei perso
Madò tutto a me capitano Come ti chiami
Come il bambino si è perso la mamma ha
pregato di venire a prelevare in cassa e
soprattutto le cambiarli nome